هل خرج الفريق البرهان بالاتفاق مع اعدائه
في الدعم السريع ساعه تكف فيها البنادق
ريث ما يبلغ مامنه هل خرج بترتيبات
اقليميه ترفع عنه اكراهات المكان وحصاره
فيه كانت الاقاويل تتكاثر والتحليلات تبعد
في النجعه حتى قرر البرهان قتلها جميعا
انا باكد انه انا مرت من القياده العامه
دي ما في زول قدم لي مساعده ولا مركت
بصفقه ولا مركت باي اتفاق مركت بالجيش ده
عمل عسكري مرتب قامت به القوات المسلحه
وقامت به وحدات الجيش اي زول يقول والله
في اتفاق والله في جهه ساعدت والله في
صفقه ذا زول عنده وهم زول موهوم في
راسه قال الفريق البرهان ان عمليه خروجه
التي شاركت فيها الاسلحه من بريه وبحريه
وجويه لم تكن سهله بل سقط اثنائها قتيلان
وجرحى وان هذه التضحيات التي قدمها الجيش
والشعب هي ثمن تخليص البلاد من محنتها كل
الشعب السوداني واقف مع الجيش وكل وحداتنا
في كل مكان واقفه وقفه واحده عشان تهزم
هذا التمرد عشان تهزم هذه الخيانه عشان
تهزم
هؤلاء المرتزقه القادمين من مختلف ا
الدنيا واذا كان نفي الصفقه عن الخروج قد
سد باب التكهنات في شانها فان ثمه خشيه من
ضغط قد يقع على البرهان للدخول في مساومه
ما فما اكثر المنابر التي سعت للتعاطي مع
الحرب في السودان سواء في مدينه جده
السعوديه حيث انطلقت اولى محاولات وقفها
او في اد سبابا حيث محاولات التدخل الخشنه
التي عبرت عنها مداولات اجتماعات منظمه
الايجاد والاتحاد الافريقي
والكيان كلاهما كانا مما فزعت اليه قوى
سودانيه سياسيه مدنيه تستقوي بهما لوقف
حرب كانت هذه القوى نفسها شهودا عليها اذ
تتخلق وكانت هذه القوه المدنيه هي عينها
التي اقترب منها الفريق حمتي واقتربت منه
قبيل الحرب يمنيه
[موسيقى]
وتمنيه التحدي الذي يواجهه البرهان هو ان
لا يسبط في منتصف الطريق بنصف انتصار ونصف
هزيمه نزولا على ترتيبات تنهي الحرب وتعيد
التموضع الدعم السريع في الجيش وفي
السياسه فاعلا ببندقيته او
بدونها وكان قائد قوات الدعم السريع
الفريق حمتي قد ذكر في اخر تصريحاته ان
نظام الحكم في السودان يجب ان يكون
فيدراليا ديمقراطيا مدنيا وبسط فكرته
بقوله ان النظام الفيدرالي غير التماثلي
هو الانسب لحكم البلاد وهو قول من ضمن
رؤيه كامله للحكم نشرها الدعم السريع غير
ان سيره الدعم السريع في عيون خصومه ما
كانت تعبر عن اي رؤيه سياسيه فقائد الدعم
السريع واخوه كان قليلي العنايه بالسياسه
كثيري الاهتمام
بمراكش كان ندا للجيش السوداني جاءت الحرب
لتكشف عن ذلك وتؤكده وما بدا رؤيه سياسيه
للحكم هي في تقدير مناهضيه افكار يتوسل
بها حميتي لاعطاء حربه مضمونا سياسيا
فاصحاب الافكار المبثوث في رؤيته موجودون
يتحركون تحت ظله وكشفت الحرب عن خسران
كبير لحمتي وقواته فقض انه يقاتل من اجل
الديمقراطيه والمدنيه واستعادتهم
هزمتها قوات حمتي بما كشفته تقارير وصفتها
الولايات المتحده بالموثوقية
المدينه لم يقع في تاريخ السودان الحديث
فالمدينه المدمره هي التجسيد المادي لفكره
المدنيه في السياسه ولهذا فان انتصار
الجيش فيما يقول سودانيون شرط لبقاء
الدوله السودانيه نفسها لان هزيمته ستعني
امرا واحدا وهو انحلال كيان الدوله ولهذا
هي بالنسبه الى السودانيين حرب وجود
ولانها كذلك فهي حرب ضروره هل يملك
البرهان وقد خرج من محبسه القدره فضلا عن
الجراه للسير ضد المزاج الرافض لنصف
انتصار ونصف
هزيمه